l'invité de France Bleu Béarn Bigorre et
Jean-Paul Mathey puisque la réforme des
retraites on en parle encore ce matin
avec vous vous êtes député des
Pyrénées-Atlantiques et président du
groupe modem à l'Assemblée nationale et
vous répondez aux questions de
mathiasquer bonjour Jean-Paul Mattei
bonjour Merci d'être en ligne avec nous
ce matin sur France Bleu Béarn Bigorre
la discussion parlementaire s'annonce
tendu sur le sujet des retraites parce
que les clivages sont là il faut le
reconnaître quel est votre position sur
le sujet est-ce que vous allez voter ce
texte en l'état sans réserve
alors nous avons déjà d'abord on a eu un
temps de concertation qu'on avait
souhaité avec François Bayrou et on est
assez satisfait de la méthode
puisqu'on s'est laissé du temps je vous
rappelle que le texte devait être adopté
au risque d'être adopté dans le cadre
d'un pdfss projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale à travers
quelques amendements donc on est
satisfait qu'on est une vraie réforme
des retraites nous allons le groupe va
voter ce texte on aimerait toutefois que
l'améliorer un petit peu sur différents
sujets notamment on souhaite qu'il y ait
une cause de revoyure en 2027
c'est-à-dire qu'on puisse faire un point
de la réforme
pour voir si effectivement les
équilibres sont respectés s'il y a pas
des effets de bord qui peuvent être
négatifs mais
nous pensons que cette réforme est
nécessaire pour équilibrer ce régime de
retraite par répartition quel fondement
un peu de notre taxe social dans notre
des pays et donc globalement le texte
nous va bien on a quelques ajustements à
apporter on espère bien que d'ici le 23
janvier date de présentation du texte
Conseil des ministres il sera amélioré
alors justement Jean-Paul Mattei à la
veille de cette mobilisation dans la rue
demain est-ce que vous comprenez tout de
même l'inquiétude de certains Français à
qui on dit aujourd'hui vous devez
travailler plus longtemps ça peut être
pénible aussi très lourd de conséquences
que l'on peut dire toutefois il faut
prendre conscience que aujourd'hui notre
système de retraite par répartition peut
être en danger quand son financement
donc nous on fait une récente et pas
forcément agréable mais qui est
nécessaire qui vient un petit peu on va
dire aggraver le dispositif Touraine
c'est-à-dire l'ancien de la réforme qui
serait en place et qui fait que
effectivement pour certains on sera
obligé de cotiser un peu plus et donc un
effet négatif mais je rappelle quand
même qu'il y a une réforme qui permet
aussi de relever les petites retraites
puisque globalement beaucoup de petites
retraites avec les trimestres validés
cotisés pardon seront relevés puisqu'on
aura des retraites à 1200 euros et qui
concernera les nouveaux entrants mais
aussi ce qu'on appelle le stock qui pour
prendre en compte les retraités actuels
est-ce que vous imaginez que sur ce
texte un passage en force du
gouvernement soit possible l'utilisation
par exemple du fameux 49-3 est-ce que ce
serait souhaitable pour un texte d'un
tel en jeu non je pense que ça serait
pas souhaitable on essaie d'obtenir des
discussions des des je dirais bon avec
nos collègues DLR certains vont voter
certainement ce très fort donc la
majorité semble assez large finalement
comment le nombre de voix sombre assez
large pour faire passer ce texte 149-3
selon vous oui moi je pense je pense
qu'on peut y arriver moi ce que je veux
être c'est qu'on n'est pas une MA aussi
un peu plus large une réforme qui peut
qui peut être juste me semble-t-il alors
je sais ce qui bloque notamment pour le
CFDT c'est l'âge de 64 ans pour 2030
mais franchement
il me semble que c'était équilibré
notamment mon site pour les carrières
longues et des carrières pénibles donc
il y a beaucoup d'avancées quand même
dans ce texte mais fondamentalement il
faut l'assumer c'est un texte qui est
nécessaire et utile pour équilibrer nos
régimes de retraite il est difficile à
assumer justement devant les Français ou
dans votre circonscription à vous par
exemple dans les pianistes même si ça
avait pas été le thème central de ma
campagne moi je pense que en
responsabilité il faut qu'on puisse
équilibrer ses régimes c'est facile de
dire on continue comme avant les régimes
sont pas équilibrés plus 33 milliards on
aura un gros déficit je rappelle que en
2020 de actifs pour un retraité en 2035
ça sera 1,5 actif pour un retraité on a
un problème d'équilibre financiers
évident si on veut conserver nous sommes
sont utiles vraiment et nécessaire ce
régime par répartition merci beaucoup
Jean-Paul